[Music]  all right listen up what you're about to  see is some real welcome soccer football  team  the light at the candy store sure was  backed up due to mother's day tomorrow  i can't believe i almost forgot mother's  day  [Music]  you said breakfast in bed wasn't messy  good grief  dear mom thank you for my school lunches  especially the bologna sandwiches not so  much the tuna fish  we got my mom an ice cream cake for  mother's day  apparently mother's day is not her  favorite holiday  i don't know why you're so upset because  you missed your mom i never had a mom  maybe you missed what moms do my dad  does all that mom stuff for me  for mother's day i'm gonna celebrate my  dad  there are all types of moms right of  course  some kids have two moms and even kids  like me can have someone who acts like a  mom and all those moms deserve to be  celebrated  [Music]